kyle uh how are you doing
i'm good thanks for having me on man
appreciate it absolutely very excited to
uh to talk to you today let's start
first with just the overarching idea of
uh becoming a sovereign individual what
would you say that really entails like
what does that mean
i think what the options given to
younger people these days is pretty
lousy compared to what it used to be and
i think most people need to be building
alternative income streams they need to
learn to invest on their own and more
than anything they need to learn to be
independent of these systems of
governments and they need to just be
ready if stuff's going to go bad in the
world and i think the whole american
dream and many of the things that
entails is no longer exactly what it
used to be and that's made it very
difficult for people to make it in this
life and there's got to be a better way
so um where were you born are you you're
american citizen or you're born
somewhere else correct yeah correct i'm
born and raised in california um i was
working as a data systems engineer at
hitachi back when i was 21 years old and
by the time i was 24 i'd moved to a
government think tank and you can
probably imagine very quickly what that
entails endless meetings endless
bureaucracies and i went to eastern
europe in 2014 and i just immediately
knew like this is where i need to be so
i started making plans to get out there
i built a couple online businesses and
in 2016 i was about 24 i quit the job
and said okay i'm going out there and
ultimately settled in ukraine and well
i'm not in ukraine anymore right now as
you can probably figure out but that's
kind of the story of the last seven or
so years of my life in a nutshell okay
so uh let's first start with why was
eastern europe so attractive to you
right coming from the united states
living in california there's plenty of
people who would say hey actually i'm
from eastern
europe and i want to get to
california i want to get to the united
states you were doing the opposite what
was so attractive to you about eastern
europe
i think mostly just so i could build a
business because i didn't think i could
do the corporate thing as well as
actually build something and be able to
afford to live in california and make it
just off the off the business alone so i
think originally i knew i could get my
cost of living down to two or three
thousand dollars a month and i had
twenty thousand dollars in the bank and
said you know what i'm just gonna go for
it and that's pretty much how it started
um but in addition you know being able
to just walk more um you know i thought
that the dating options were a little
bit better just a very different
lifestyle than what you would be used to
in america you know we're driving
everywhere commuting the nine to five
strip malls very very different up there
got it and so when you think about uh
eastern europe uh you ended up in
ukraine what was so attractive about
ukraine itself was it just like the
epitome of all those things you just
described
very much so and i also thought that it
was very much a tipping point it was a
place that was just starting to get a
little bit more westernized and you've
seen all to see all the western support
for ukraine during this crisis and so it
was just about the tip where things were
a little bit more convenient there were
some good investing opportunities the
the whole society seemed to be learning
more english so i thought you know it
was very much on the cutting edge of
flipping a little more western which
there are some downsides to that as well
as still having a lot of those other
kind of more or old world values and a
little bit more going on for it in that
sense as well got it and so in order to
be able to do this you had the corporate
job then you're working at the think
tank you mentioned that you had to build
businesses what was so important about
doing that what would you just want to
get in a financial position where you
could kind of live anywhere in the world
and have like online businesses or what
was that
exactly yeah so i started out originally
with just a dating blog and then that
did well i built a few other like little
travel sites some did affiliate
marketing with that and then of course
obviously i was still building my own
brand my blog i started teaching a
little bit about seo and what i learned
from that and then when i got out to
eastern europe a few years in i started
an olive oil company with a friend that
i met a reader of the blog
and from there i just kind of kept
building stuff and now one of my main
things is a ukrainian recruiting company
so i saw a gap in the market where you
know a lot of filipinos a lot of indians
but there wasn't a lot of people in
eastern europe that were looking for
these online jobs so that was you know
there's been holes there's been
opportunities um with me being out there
that i've been able to step into and
take advantage of walk me through like
when you think about starting a business
how do you evaluate the various
businesses you could start do you have
some sort of like research process do
you measure the market what are the
metrics that are important to get you to
the point where you're like yep this
would be a good business to start and
i'm gonna do it
i really just stumbled into a lot of
what i did like i said originally it was
just i got to find a way to make it and
i didn't know exactly what was that was
going to entail so i stumbled into it
and then you know these days obviously i
would be evaluating you know what's the
payoff i've got these other projects
i've got this going on you know what am
i going to do what's
you know what's the roi on this
potentially you know what's the
opportunity if i'm going to sell it one
day what's that going to entail so
there's a lot that would go into it but
ultimately starting out you know it was
just a lot of stumbling and you know
that's the big thing about entrepreneurs
is most of us don't have any idea what
we're doing when we start out it's just
a little bit of luck and a lot of great